-Our next guest can be seen
at the New York Comedy Cellar
Tuesday, October 19th.
Making his "Tonight Show" debut,
please welcome the very funny
Tom Thakkar.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you. Hey. Oh, my gosh.
Holy moly! Look at you!
Oh, my gosh!
This is incredible.
It's so good to be here.
I've been aging rapidly!
I've been catching myself just
saying old-people stuff lately.
I was walking down the street
the other day,
and I just heard myself go,
"That post office
used to be a bank!"
Who cares?
That's not a good story.
That sucks.
That's an old-person story,
you know?
They're always telling you
stuff like that.
They're like, "That pizza place
was a spaghetti place before!"
"All right. Did you like
the spaghetti place?"
"No! It just was.
You have to know what was."
[ Laughter ]
I'm not -- I'm not that old yet.
I'll know I'm really old when
I have a loud clock in my house.
Old people always have
the loudest clocks.
You stay with an old person,
their clock is like,
"Bing, bong! Ding, dong!
Ding, dong! Bing, bong!
Bong!
Bong!"
And then they're always like,
"I had trouble sleeping
last night."
You're like,
"Yeah, I wonder why."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
I'm from Indiana.
I live in New York.
But my family refuses
to visit me here and my friends,
because they're all scared
of New York.
They think it's too dangerous,
which is crazy 'cause Indiana
is the most dangerous place
I've ever been.
When I was a kid,
our main form of entertainment
was a trampoline
that didn't have
the guard-net thing around it.
Those are like
little kid death traps.
Every kid hobbles away like,
"Ugh.
We lost Jeremy back there.
And I'm different now."
My brother broke his leg
on our trampoline immediately
'cause did he that thing
where he was like,
"I'm gonna go as high as I can
on the new trampoline,"
and then he did,
and then he started
to float away
from the trampoline.
You know that moment
where you see somebody
suspended in the air
and you're like, "Oh, no.
We're about to hear
a new noise.
[ Laughter ]
That's going to be crazy."
But, uh, my brother broke
his leg, and then he made me --
We didn't want to tell my mom
what happened
'cause we didn't want
to lose the trampoline.
So he made me drag him
into the house,
and then when my mom got home,
we told her that my uncle
broke my brother's leg.
[ Laughter ]
Because we were more willing
to lose him than a bouncy tarp,
so...
I got banned on Twitter
last year. This is true.
Because I got super into this
show called "My Cat From Hell."
I don't know
if guys have seen it.
It's the best show.
It's on Animal Planet.
It's like "The Dog Whisperer,"
but for cats.
And the host's name
is Jackson Galaxy,
and he calls himself
"The Cat Daddy."
It's incredible.
And I was watching it.
I was like, "Man.
I bet this show has the best
Twitter account of all time
with all these crazy cat people
and Jackson Galaxy."
I looked it up. They didn't
have a Twitter account!
But now they do.
Because I made one.
I made a Twitter account
for "My Cat From Hell."
And I got like 15,000 followers
because I played it straight.
All I would tweet was like,
"Check out the show.
Sundays at 9:00." You know?
"What was your favorite meowment
from tonight's episode?"
I did that for an entire year
like a psycho.
And it was so believable
that when people interviewed
the host of the show,
they'd tag my Twitter account.
They'd be like, "Follow him
here," and everybody did.
And then a year in, I got drunk,
and I was like,
"Let's burn this thing down."
You know?
[ Laughter ]
So, my first move
was I tweeted out,
"Hey, send in a picture
of your cat,
and I'll give it a rating
from 1 to 10."
And I got thousands
of cat pictures,
and I gave them all 3's.
And people were so mad.
I thought they might think
it was funny. They did not.
They were like,
"How dare you disrespect
my cat and my family."
And I was just like, "Hey, I'm
sorry your cat's a butter tail.
I don't know
what you want from me.
I'm not attracted to your little
kitty cat, you pervert."
But I'd spell "pervert"
P-U-R-R-V-E-R-T.
Stay on brand.
But what got me in trouble
was people were asking me
for cat advice all the time,
and I didn't know anything
about cats.
But I started giving advice.
A lot of it was, like,
people going,
"Hey, my cat scratches our faces
every day."
And I was like,
"You've got to change
that cat's name, brother."
The one that really got me
in trouble, though,
is this guy goes, "Hey, my cat
keeps going to the bathroom
next to the litter box,
but he won't go inside.
Next to it.
I don't know what to do."
And I was like, "Look,
cats are very observant,
perceptive creatures.
Sometimes they need to
see you go in the litter box
before they know what to do."
And right before I got banned,
I just saw one tweet
from that dude that was like,
"This is not working."
All right. I'm Tom Thakkar.
Thank you guys very much!
♪♪
-Hey!
That's how you do it, brother.
Oh, my gosh. Fantastic!
Tom Thakkar!
[ Cheers and applause ]
He will be at
the New York Comedy Cellar
Tuesday, October 19th.